here's a veiled parent question that i'm
gonna pretend is for the audience but
it's really just
two dads talking here i got a 10 year
old son hank and a five-year-old
daughter josephine
and one of the things i loved in your
book is
your parents had and i've got capital
letters here in my notes
they had expectations for you right
they had expectations they expected you
to live by the family codes
they expected you to do what they said
and sometimes i love the expectations
right because every family's got their
outspoken ones and then they're like
this is the way we the way we do things
right
but we live in a culture run by children
where parents are trying to catch up
with their kids and make sure
everybody's smiling and happy what
advice do you have for parents trying to
navigate that responsibility
to their kids i'm often telling people
over and over
this world's desperate for adults to
step up and say no to their kids and
show their kids that they love them
what's some advice you got for parents
good man
participation trophies are doing a
disservice to our kids
come on it's a lie right now it's a
it's it's it's so irresponsible to them
because the real world don't give
participation trophies so as soon as
they're out of the house
and they're out there thinking oh all
they got to do is show up to to get it
to get the trophy in life life goes
yeah and and you may even get you may it
may even get bloody and you learn that
whoa
it's harsh at us i'm saying it's a rodeo
i'm not trying to scare
i don't think we need to scare our
children into you better do this and if
you don't win you're
not worth no that's not the point um
look you know
if we're not we want to be we want to be
friends with our kids sure
but man i know the the parents i know
that are that's their first priority i
want to be my
kids best friend at the sacrifice of
being the father of the mother
most of those kids are turds man that's
exactly right i tell folks a lot man
get your own friends dude be their mom
and dad that
you don't need and they need it and
let's give ourselves
adults let's give ourselves you said
let's give ourselves more credit if we
don't know better in situation
situations
what the hell is evolution for that's
exactly right
we're going through that and i
understand they're going to go through
it a different way
but it's that old thing about look i
look at like a tree limb kids aren't
afraid
of heights until they fall right so
when you're in the backyard and they're
climbing that tree
and they're out on that land that you're
like that's pretty damn high man if they
fall from there
measure it like well they fall from
there they're not gonna break their arm
but they're going to get bruised
and scratched and we're going to see
some tears maybe that's a good limb to
let them keep walking
when they get way up there we were like
oh boy they don't come back with this
one right
that's maybe when we need to step in and
go hey come on over here come here check
this out come on down a minute
you know what i mean down but we don't
want to pull them off the
the lower limbs so quickly pull them off
the lower limbs too quickly before they
can go
i mean i went to school i passed all the
tests made my haze
what do i remember what i experienced
what i tried out and failed at what i
tried out and was embarrassed of what i
tried out and succeeded at
i remember you know what what what what
happened the consequence of the
situation that i got to experience
not more so than i did the one i learned
from the book
and if we're it's i think it's important
for all of us to want
we want our kids to be able to go out
and negotiate life right
and we want them to go out on their own
and leave the nest
one day and say thank you mom dad for
preparing me for this world and helping
me be who i am
so i can now go navigate on my own
that's what our parents want to do we
want to see our kids go
and leave the flock we want to see them
go their own way
i i this is a theory i have on um that i
believe
i know it's true for me and i think it's
true for for a lot of parents
and even us as a nation we raise our
kids in a structure
all right follow these rules stay within
these guidelines all right and if we do
that if the kids do that
they're going to usually have a good
chance to succeed
but what do we really want as parents
what do we really want as a nation
with governments and regulations hey
stay in line you've got to follow the
rules
yes do that but what we really want is
when our kid
or an entrepreneur comes to us and goes
thank you but i'm going my own way and
i'm not asking permission
that's when a mom and dad really go yes
and you are bluffing and if you do steve
jobs
i'm going to do this wait a minute no
you can't do that yes i am he goes
all of a sudden he does it pulls it off
the world goes wow
[Music]
when i called my dad and told him i
didn't want to go to law school i want
to go to film school
in that phone call he could hear my
voice that i really wasn't asking him
permission i would have wobbling well i
think i maybe want to you know he just
said boyd
nice pipe dream you're going to law
school like you planned but he heard my
voice
even though i was asking him a question
technically i wasn't asking permission
that's right you asking for a blessing
that's a different thing right
yeah and then hearing that he was like
don't half-ass
and i heard ryan going he felt like ah i
did a good job as a dad
that i raised my son in a structure long
enough you learn to block and tackle
before you go play wide out son
right you raise the structure
early you learn the fundamentals and
then if you want to let it fly and go
off on your own way
go but don't come a bluffing when you go
that's where the world are
muffin too yeah you can feel it right
that's what your agent told you right
or your uh buddy there in in hollywood
out the gate people can smell
desperation
right you come out here needy you are
done
get go forget about hollywood for a
minute forget about getting an agent
and i'll let you know when you're ready
when i came back and wasn't like i gotta
have an asian i gotta that's when he
said you're ready and he was right